bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors qu à la
bouche de vente a été arrêté cette nuit
en sardaigne votre réaction quand vous
avez appris son arrestation
bonjour fois j'ai été très surpris
puisque au regard du droit européen
cette arrestation est totalement
illégale en effet la dernière décision
de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
avait effectivement suspendu la
l'immunité parlementaire de monsieur
plus emon qui nous bien nous l'oublions
pas est député européen mais également
ils avaient suspendu tous les mandats
d'arrêt européen jusqu'à ce que la cour
ne statue sur le fond et sur les
questions préjudicielles présenté par le
tribunal suprême espagnol par conséquent
à l'heure actuelle j'estime et même en
tant que juriste j'estime que le juge
italien devrait d'ores et déjà le
remettre en liberté et renoncer à
l'extradition il faut tenir compte aussi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui même la cour de
justice de l'union européenne a été
saisie par carlos forcément nous par ses
avocats dans le but de précisément de
bloquer cette procédure italienne et
d'empêcher justement de confirmer la
décision antérieure et d'empêcher le
léger italien de d'accepter
l'extradition vers l'espagne de monsieur
carlos boozer ça veut dire que selon
vous ils bénéficièrent de l'immunité
parlementaire encore aujourd'hui
de fait c'est à dire ils ne bénéficient
pas en droit puisque le la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire a été maintenue
par le cos la cour de justice de l'union
européenne mais en contrepartie la le la
cour de justice de l'union européenne a
dit clairement d'une part qu' il pour
pouvoir exercer son mandat de député
européen et pouvaient voyager partout
librement en europe et deuxièmement que
il suspendait par contre tous les
mandats européens mandat d'arrêt
européen je temple que l la cour n'aura
pas statué sur le fond delà de la levée
de l'immunité parlementaire ce qui n'a
pas un n'est pas encore le cas a donc
par conséquent ce mandat d'arrêt
européen n'est pas valable aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas l'utiliser en tout cas on
ne sait pas encore s'il sera extradé si
oui rappelez-nous ans pour quel motif un
carrelet plus de monde et il poursuivi
par la justice espagnole
alors il est il est poursuivi comme
c'est les autres membres du gouvernement
catalan
avait organisé qui ont été condamnés à
de très lourdes peines
n'oublions pas
qu'ils ont été condamnées parce que il
avait organisé un référendum sur
l'indépendance de la catalogne le 1er
octobre 2017 et carrelage pizza mode est
poursuivi pour ces mêmes faits
c'est-à-dire des faits de de sédition et
de et de rébellion
oui alors on sait que l'arrestation est
survenue quelques jours il me semble une
semaine après la reprise des
négociations entre le gouvernement
central et l'exécutif régional catalan
est ce que cette arrestation ça va
mettre un terme un peu un frein à ce
dialogue à ces négociations
il faut dire que ce dialogue est mort né
tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement espagnol ne veut pas dû
aussi tout simplement il faut le dire
clairement parce que ils n'ont pas
accepté à l'ordre du jour les points
demandés par le gouvernement catalan
donc je vois difficilement que ceux de
négociations puissent se poursuivre si
dans le pire des cas monsieur pop damon
été extradé vers l'espagne
l'a7 ce dialogue et cette négociation
est définitivement morte de mon point de
vue alors au niveau des mobilisations
c'est qu'il y en a déjà eu aujourd'hui
ans notamment en italie est ce que vous
savez s'il ya d'autres mobilisations qui
sont prévues notamment barcelone oui à
barcelone en toute la matinée il ya eu
des manifestations
devant le siège du consulat
d'italie et d'autres manifestations sont
prévues mais également les prises de
position de la classe politique catalane
qui a dénoncé une nouvelle pas eu de
telles pratiques et notamment du
gouvernement
autonome catalan de monsieur p la
ragonnaise qui a lui même
dénoncé cette tête de ces mesures prises
à l'heure actuelle et s'est solidarisé
avec monsieur carlos pour ce monde et je
pense que déjà on a vu que le 11
septembre il y a eu quatre cent mille
personnes dans la rue à barcelone ce qui
a été la manifestation la plus
importante depuis la crise sanitaire de
toute l'europe d'ailleurs je voudrais le
préciser est que à l'heure actuelle déjà
depuis plusieurs mois même si la crise
sanitaire n'a pas fait beaucoup parler
de la catalogne il est évident qu'il ya
un
démobilisation de plus en plus
importante et que des mouvements vont
avoir lieu dans les prochains jours si
jamais monsieur carlos ghosn était
extradé et je pense que l'espagne a
intérêt à arrêter
7,7 cette politique de la carotte et du
bâton qui ne mène absolument à rien et
qu'il fait présager dans l'impossibilité
d'une quelconque négociation dans la
mesure où on ne peut plus avoir
confiance si tenté qu'il y en a jamais
pu avoir avec l'état espagnol qu'il soit
des partis dits de gauche comme le psoe
ou des partis de droite qui sur la
question catalan ni suspense exactement
la même chose tous les partis de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
ce sont des partis nationalistes
espagnols est qui et qui ne tolère pas
une quelconque revendication catalan
même silence en très grande partie
responsable parce que la catalogne situé
le parc et l'espagne c'est tout
simplement par une situation de
ras-le-bol forte unie merci en tout cas
d'avoir donné à votre avis sur arte
france je m'appelle vous êtes président
de l'assemblée nationale catalane en
france merci f merci